Hey it's me Destin, welcome
back to Smarter Every Day.
I want to do something a
little bit different today,
let's start with a story. Once there
was a kingdom where wealth was
determined by what sheep you owned. There
was a rich man who had many, many sheep.
Even his sheep were rich. There was
also a peasant family who only had
one sheep but they loved her very much.
The father of the house wanted
her to be the very best
sheep she could be, so he
spent lots of time with her.
The sheep was basically a part of the family
and it participated in almost every aspect
of their lives. One day a
traveller came to town to visit
the rich man and they
became business partners.
That evening they were
hungry but the rich man was
unwilling to take from his
own flock so the traveller
pointed out to the peasant sheep. The
rich man's cook then took the sheep and
cut out the tasty parts. Together the
rich man and the traveller enjoyed
the feast and their bellies were full.
This crushed the family. The father
asked the rich man for another
sheep but he was ignored.
Oh man, that's sad.
But it's real. The sheep is your
YouTube video, and the rich
man is Facebook. The traveller
is someone who uploads your
video to Facebook so the two of
them can use what's yours and
make money off of it. How do
internet videos make money?
You've seen the ads at the
beginning of the video
and you've heard that people
make a living on YouTube right?
But what you don't know is it takes
a ridiculous number of these ads
in order to make any kind of significant income.
This is why people jump at the opportunity
to get a sponsor for their videos.
In fact there will be a sponsor
at the end of this very video.
Sometimes the videos themselves take
a lot of time and money to create.
Other times people just upload a video on a
whim and have a viral success on their hands.
Either way the people made the
video and they deserve to reap any
success or profit that comes from it right?
Here's the problem though.
Sometimes people will steal a video and then
re-upload it as if they created it themselves.
Flula is a German DJ friend of mine
who uploaded this hilarious video
to YouTube called Jennifer is a Party Pooper.
This thing got over five million views in
four years, which sounds
awesome until you realize that
a verified Facebook page downloaded
this video and then re-uploaded
it into the Facebook player where it
received the same five million views
in four days. Facebook's algorithm
prefers videos that are
uploaded into its video player. Facebook
ran ads on five million views of
Flula's video and made money off of it. I
wonder what Flula has to say about this.
It's like I made a present for my friends
but then another person stole my present,
wrapped it up and said "Hey
everyone, look at this present
I made for you!". Doh.
They ate his sheep. Eventually he
got Facebook to take the video
down and I'm sure they were happy to do it
because they had already made their money.
This is a serious issue and it's worth talking
about. It's even been given
a name by Brady Haran
from Hello Internet. - Freebooting.
- Freebooting. - Freebooting.
- Freebooting is the act of taking a
creation that someone else has made
and then using it as if you
made it, in order to profit.
Brady has a dozen channels that are really
high quality so he's freebooted often.
This is a video he created of his
dog Audrey playing with bubbles.
You'll notice that somebody else uploaded
it, and Facebook's running ads on it.
150,000 people have seen this. This
one's been viewed 1.2 million times but
it's been shared 34,000 times.
That's about 34.5 views per share.
This one doesn't even
have a view count on it.
If you look, it's been shared over a
quarter million times and if we multiply
times that previous ratio,
that's over 9.1 million views.
What is happening? Smarter Every
Day has also been a victim to
this. In September I
uploaded the tattoo in slow
motion video and it was my
largest success to date.
The largest privately owned
publishing company in Europe
called Bauer Media Group, downloaded the
video, cut out all the educational content,
cut out my sponsor, and cut out all
links back to Smarter Every Day
and then re-uploaded it to
their verified Facebook page.
I filled out forms, I sent emails, I
exhausted every option given to me by both
of these multi-billion dollar corporations.
It was the most successful post
ever made to their Facebook page.
So as I'm trying to get
it taken down over here,
someone within the company is
re-uploading it and saying
"In case you missed it". It wasn't
until the followers of Smarter Every
Day on Twitter re-tweeted this
tweet over 100 times that
Facebook responded. Which is interesting.
The slower and more drawn
out the process is,
the more ads they can run against the
video before they finally shut it down.
By the time it was eventually taken down,
the video had been viewed on Facebook over
17 million times. I can tell you this.
17 million views would have been some
serious, serious college fund money.
So after 17 million views, this email was
sent from Dwayne at community operations at
Facebook. "We understand
this action to resolve your
intellectual property issue." Facebook
is currently designed so that when
you finally do get that viral video, you
can see all of the financial benefit that
you've dreamed of whisked away
in other people's Facebook news
feeds and you'll be stuck
with an email saying that
they understand that they've solved
your intellectual property issue.
I am not trying to get you to
feel sorry for Smarter Every Day.
I am so incredibly blessed and I am grateful
for everything that I have been entrusted
with. But I understand
also that not everyone has
a channel with 2 million intelligent subscribers.
So this happens thousands of times every day
to people who have no voice
and they have no recourse.
They try to make this sound all
complicated, but it's not.
Even my children can understand
what's going on here.
(Destin) But they were hungry, so it's OK?
- No it's not.
- Why not?
- Because it's someone else's sheep.
- Yeah but they were hungry.
- And they should replace it, the traveller
should.
- Why should the traveller replace it?
- Because he pointed it out.
- But what if I told you that every single
day the rich man gets another traveller to
bring him somebody else's sheep. What do
you think about that?
- That is enough to go to jail.
- Why? - Because he's stealing every day.
- Oh. It's pretty simple isn't it.
- But what if there is no jails?
- You know he's got a good point. What if
there are no consequences for freebooting
other people's content? I mean
people are telling me that there's
no way an individual like you or me can go
up against multiple multi-billion dollar
organizations. But is that true?
And we're gonna be ruined financially.
Really?
I mean if a six year old and an eight year old
can understand the social injustice that's
occurred, we have laws.
Don't you think a court of
law can do the same thing?
Maybe it's just that doing the right
thing is sometimes difficult,
and scary. As of the upload
of this video, the two people
that ate my sheep, the rich man
and the traveller, have refused
to compensate, which I get.
That's really smart actually.
Drag it out, make it hurt, hope that
the offended party loses interest.
Facebook freebooting has got
to stop, and you can help.
Any time you see freebooted content, anywhere
on the internet, do these three things.
Capture, comment, contact. Capture
the freebooting. Take a screen shot
or if you really want to document it, video
screen capture the freebooter stealing the
content. Comment on the
freebooted material.
State that it's stolen and point
people back to the original source.
Contact the content creator and then
give them the freebooting evidence
as well as the link to the freebooting. The
creator can then decide what legal action
to take. Doing this will let
the content creator spend
more time with their sheep. I apologize
if you detected any negativity
in this video, that's not the intent.
I just want to be a voice
for people without a voice.
For example Gordon, the guy that
creates music for Smarter Every Day.
His music was also freebooted and as you
can see here it makes him really sad.
Here's the deal. I pay Gordon so
we're gonna pay the bills right now
with our sponsor, which is Audible.com. If you
want to support us go to audible.com/smarter,
download any audio book you choose. I
recommend Ender's Game by Orson Scott Card.
Let me tell you why. When I was
getting ready to make this video
I listened to Ender's Game
and it totally pumped me up.
Ender is a weak little boy
that doesn't like to fight
but people always try to get after him. He
uses his superior intellect, even though
he's weaker, to defeat these
foes, and he's so good at
it that the whole human
race selects him to use
techniques, tactics and
procedures to defend them
against an invading alien species. It's
so well written that the United States
Marine Corps uses it as a recommended book.
It's amazing. So, go get Ender's
Game by Orson Scott Card.
It really helped me understand how
a weak man could even approach
a superior foe. I recommend it.
Even if you just read it.
Just go experience Ender's
Game by Orson Scott Card.
You can get it for free at audible.com/smarter.
Again, thank you for sticking with me.
I'm Destin, you're getting Smarter
Every Day. Have a good one.